my name is IRISA I'm from Ontario Canada
yeah my question is um first of all I
run a super girl fashion blog where I
find that clothes that all of you guys
wear on the show and they post it for
people to buy and cosplay on you know so
it kind of relates to that is there
something your character has worn that
you have taken home or wanted to take
none of us would ever take anything home
I mean that would be a robbery down I
don't know what's gonna hit that guy
Noel I don't take ideas yeah yeah like a
lot of ideas
Alex dresses a lot cooler than me so why
can't I just like yeah my one to take
the suit home but I think later is
probably under her to take us into the
home I'm sure I wanted to try to
trick-or-treat in it last year I
actually I'm sorry I shouldn't ride a
ride a motorbike and I really wanted to
go down the street riding dressed as
John Jones but riding this Harley it's
creepy and oh cool oh my god that
capable to look oh the camera got
clogged no we look at this no guy yeah
all right next up Robert yes uh hi my
name is Aiden I'm from San Antonio Texas
yeah yeah Texas Texas you know yeah uh
this question goes to Melissa how did it
feel to meet the first Super Girl and
did she give you any advice
she gave me a lot of advice and I Helen
Slater is another she is super girl yeah
she is amazing and she was so sweet and
kind to me and you know we talked about
flying techniques and we talked about
training how we learned how to fight and
she got to do some really cool stuff
like horseback riding and archery and
trampoline training which I was pretty
jealous of um but yeah she's amazing and
I loved working with her that was pretty
cool I love your Thanksgiving scene the
Thanksgiving dinner yeah yeah thank you
thank you yeah you're so brave he's so
sweet way to go Robin all right are you
Carmen Sandiego I am indeed finally
nowhere in the world chair weight world
and where in the world are you what you
nobody know she was in San Diego that
game was on I'm famous Janice I always
ignore intended Karen San Diego is in
San Diego
hi I'm Emily Marsh from Redwood City and
my question yeah my question is because
your cast is so full of Broadway and
Glee stars including the flash and even
Astra is there any possibility in the
future of a musical episode
we deflect the sarah-jane silly not to
recognize all the talent that we have at
our disposal so we've thought about it
in an evil song definitely thought about
it it would be K it's pretty much like a
musical all the time on our set
everybody's singing all the time usually
Melissa breaking out into dance Jeremy
breaking into song Macaulay just
breaking stuff yeah it's kind of what do
it all the time also also Melissa knows
every lyric to every rap song ever I've
never seen she's like a rapid our video
Oh Melissa why don't you do one for us
right now I think I prefer yet you can
go like you just like sensory you can do
like the kid bop surgeon gets pocket ha
ha or we can go it's another question
yeah maybe we move on yeah sure she
likes 90s hardcore I mean oh yeah pretty
right yeah it's not it was all a dream I
just read Word Up Magazine a little more
spin from what hi my name is Haley and
what's up my question is for Jeremy and
my cot so Jimmy Olsen is one of my
favorite original characters like you
and your version isn't exactly very much
like the original
but I don't know today I have no clue
what you talking about but when is
closer so did you take anything from
original Jimmy and how did you become
James interesting
wait wait wait huh well how did I become
James I'm sorry can you what do you mean
what you how did you make yourself into
the character and then dude
got here maybe come uh yeah I mean I you
know when we first got the script Anaya
and I didn't know what James was gonna
look like but but as soon as I saw when
I was like oh this is like that sort of
character like the character that's kind
of the the fanboy in all of us the kind
of closest probably to a lot of you like
if you were in the world you probably
would react to a lot of the thing the
way that Wynn reacts like when we see
when meets Superman next season is
probably going to be exactly how you
would react if you met Superman pretty
much how I just reacted when I met
Superman so that's that's what kind of
Jimmy Olsen II qualities that I take
from him but uh yeah it's yeah he's a
little different than me and um when I
was auditioning
yeah I'm taller when I was when I was
auditioning and I kept going in my
manager is like yeah they really like
you I go they know I'm black right they
know that right
oh yeah it's all good so then I got the
role I was like Oh dating um and I
thought I was gonna get fired like every
15 minutes in the pilot cuz like I'm not
the traditional Jimmy Olsen so I kept
asking you know Ali Adler who's who was
on set and I said well you know who's
Jimmy Olsen she's like well he's you I
go you know I'm black right you know and
she's like nothing that is matter
we still see the DNA of Jimmy in you and
so yeah thank you so I just I'm kind of
a fan boy melon right and I think that
we're just sort of redefining the
character for the 21st century
you know
like when Jimmy was created him 75 years
ago and so things were a lot more
monochromatic back then so if they were
it's a very PC or disease yeah so not
here to ruffle feathers I'm just here to
tell the truth so if if Jimmy
if Jimmy was uh was created today he
might look like me he might look like he
might me like Jimmy Chen you know you
don't know but uh so we're kind of
writing the inequities of the past I
would also say that macaw is generally
kind of cooler right you're a little bit
cooler and more suave than one might
traditionally think of Jimmy Olsen but
that was what we wanted now is the
intention of the pilot which is you know
what Jimmy Olsen duck like you can't be
really lame and be Superman's best
friend like I just don't think that
would happen and so and Mike Honda
seemed like someone that could be best
friends with Superman
right thank you ah thank you that's
right not Superman just best friends
with cigarette oh but I should not lose
my nerd card because that she says him
suave I'm also a nerd so that fits in
true true yeah go ahead
um come hi my name is Albert
I'm from stammer originally from San
Bernardino but San Diego [ __ ] now I'm
so excited to see the cast here my
question is since they introduced the
omegahedron Oh from Season Finale are we
going to see supergirls hometown Argo
city in space or underwater wow that's
very specific was that was a deep cut
deeper greg berlanti where are you right
yeah I have a very deep question what if
we see it in outer space underwater
Oh
don't don't don't feed him please feed
me you're a sailor moon' shirt this is
what that is like everyday yeah oh yeah
I love that shirt nice excellent thank
you how is that for an answer
all right this is good this is actually
going to be our last question so don't
mess it up the last question yeah no
pressure no no no pressure no pressure
um okay thank you guys for being here
it's wonderful to have your cast and
everybody here I have a quick question
for the whole cast
how are you similar and how are you
different to your characters where do
you want to start sorry David Tyler I'm
I'm I'm give me a second
yeah yeah I'm giving Tyler a second go
ahead David I'm similar in that like
Jean Jones I have two daughters and like
John when I'm filming away I miss them
so it is it is nice having these two
girls and my surrogate daughters because
I love these two equally so it's really
solos handled girl yes
I'm gonna take a moment cuz that was
really really sweet and that um yeah
civil similarly I guess in in a lot of
ways like I'm a mom and I'm a wife and
my family always comes first no matter
what and so I guess in that way I'm very
similar to Alex because I fight for my
family
and I mean I'll fight to the death for
my family and for this one you know I
would do the same thing you know
different though is like I kicked some
serious as Alex and you know at home I
just put kids in timeout so I guess that
would be kind of yeah like and dislike
hmm um I tend whenever I am Cara in the
glasses and Catco that's I I and I just
feel like in essence I'm playing a
version of myself because I feel like
that weird uh poor girl she does that
all the time so we're you guys that was
like an old woman um but I think in the
difference that I yeah in the same way
like I don't feel nearly as brave as I
feel Cara is um I have moments but she
never gives up and she is braver by far
than I have ever been in my life so I
think that's where I'm different car is
also less clumsy true okay this is true
yeah I am glum seeker this
I'm gonna hide it now I guess I guess in
I'm a lot like James in a lot of ways in
the fact that he believes in truth and
justice and equality and trying to save
the world in his own way I in that in a
very corny way and I think this world
needs healing and she called me medicine
man I want I want to help with that um
that's really cool thank you
and um I'm also kind of a hopeless
romantic like he is yeah you guys
sometimes sometimes I just kind of feel
hopeless and , and been romantic but I
kind of James in our kind of the same
with that so yeah yeah I'm done
um you know I win is probably the most
similar character to me that I've ever
played uh you know he's a little bit
he's a little bit smarter than me book
wise maybe not socially but yeah I mean
I as soon as I saw the
he laughs at his own inside jokes like
all the time and no I mean what was
really interesting me to me was to see
sort of wins journey to the first season
and that has kind of been my own journey
from like high school to now like I was
super quiet and really reserved and
nerdy and now I'm much more outgoing and
I still have a ways to go and so it was
kind of that that journey for when
really mirrored my my journey you know
to adulthood and maturity we're not
quite there yet uh uh but yeah I Supes
it's all up to you now um follow that I
can't fly I don't see through walls a
lot of other qualities about him that I
wish I have that I don't I did always
say if I had a power would be to fly so
this will be fun but I think the the
thing about Superman and Clark that I
really identify with is just being
passionate about what you do just two
things in life that I've been passionate
about as far as work it's been you know
baseball and working with great people
like this so I've been so anxious for
the last four or five weeks to get up to
Vancouver and start working because I'm
just really excited and I love doing
what I do especially with good people so
I would say that and just you know being
able to be a voice for people that don't
always have one I think that's something
that he stands for and whether it's
vocal or through actions I think he does
that really well and that's kind of
something that I aspire to do so
hopefully I can live up to a portion of
that it's a lot like wholesome question
yeah extra question great question thank
you all and let's give a hand to this
amazing panel Supergirl takes off on the
CW
this fall
you